absolument la crau qui quittent l'élysée
pour remonter les champs elysées alors
voilà le sens lorraine s'est levé sur la
voiture et dans un véhicule qui n'est
pas une des ss oui ça c'est l'ubs a un
petit peu moins bien jusqu'au bout des
digues
exactement c'est son rôle de chef des
armées relativement là qu'il prend à
bras le corps voilà je très honnêtement
je ne sais pas exactement comment
s'appelle ce véhicule mais c'est
clairement un véhicule militaire sur
laquelle ça c'est toujours le président
mais sur lequel emmanuel même s'apprête
à remonter les champs elysées juste pour
conclure la toux qui lassé qui parle
très bien anglais ce qui n'était pas le
cas des deux prédécesseurs répond en
anglais emmanuel mac temps en temps il
pose des questionnements et puis devant
gala merkel ou l'un se sont vite parler
de la langue de l'autre même si macron
dit la langue de l'europe c'est la
traduction comme disait une verte aux
échos et bien là il va vous parler en
anglais mais il parle aussi bien l'un
que l'autre très bien anglais savaient
traducteur un comptoir effrayant de
retirer ses forces de la nouveauté
une nouveauté par rapport aux enjeux qui
se posent aujourd'hui sur l'europe et
sur le rapport entre ces deux pays et
ses deux chefs d'état on voit donc
emmanuel macron qui commencent à
remonter des champs elysées il salue la
foule on a peut-être voulu attendre
quelques instants que l'averse se
terminant au point de vraiment
exactement tout à fait maître des
horloges et et de la météo on voit que
la a priori à peut-être quelques gouttes
mais en tout cas le ciel est beaucoup
plus clément la garde républicaine qui
ouvrent le cortège
et puis à emmanuel macron qui salue dans
un véhicule militaire ouvert du coup
tous les les passants peuvent voir le
président de la république c'est nicolas
sarkozy qui disait que la météo et
notamment la baraka en général faisait
partie de la bonne gestion
vous voilà avec ce symbole du président
nouveau installé dans un mini char
l'idée que l'on peut se faire aussi dans
l'inconscient des français de ce que
représente la sécurité de ce qu'elle
représente l'état d'urgence de ce que
représente l'armée regardé comme jean
yves le drian est célébré comme étant un
grand ministre de la défense en élimant
unanimement à droite et à gauche et
comment et comment il a pu rendre son
arme et enfin l'armée française proche
des français et donc toute cette
symbolique là là on voit bien emmanuel
macron a compris ce message est
peut-être juste sur cette idée là que la
france c'est aussi sa défense c'est
aussi sa sécurité
et c'est ça qui est important
aujourd'hui nomme philippe goulliaud il
ya la volonté chez ce très jeune
président au fond sur lequel il y avait
pas mal d'interrogations d'entrée tout
de suite dans les habits de chef de
l'état chef des armées c'est vraiment
très frappant cette image est très
instructif de vue là on ne naît pas
président on le devient
incontestablement aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron a compris l'importance de cette
journée dans la métamorphose qui doit le
faire passer effectivement du président
élu au président en exercice
tu l'avais vu laquelle on est en train
d'assister alors qu'on voit un emmanuel
macron remonter donc cette avenue des
champs elysées dans ce qu'on appelle un
véhicule léger de reconnaissance
avancées dont dans le jargon militaire
ça ne vient pas de moi je ne vous le
cache pas et on va retrouver valais les
brochard qui elle est sur les champs
elysées au milieu des badauds qui sont
venus saluer le passage du président de
la république on vous retrouve tout de
suite vallée et qui sont même venus de
loin puisque monia vient de belgique
bonjour qu'est ce que vous êtes venu
voir ici mais on est venu voir bas
l'investiture du nouveau président donc
c'est important parce que voilà les
français sont nos voisins sa peau c'est
l'europe et puis c'est vraiment
important c'est un président jeune on
s'attend à ce que bon voilà il ya les
choses changent bouche un souffle
et donc voilà on est venu soutenir
ce moment historique vous êtes assez
près vous pensez pouvoir le saluer je
pense oui on est bien situé et on a fait
en sorte comme le soir merci beaucoup
monnet à merci merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup valérie donc on avait avec vous
les gens sont venus tôt certains sont
venus de loin
pascal perrineau il n'y a pas non plus
une foule extraordinaire on a
l'impression sur les champs elysées non
il n'ya pas une foule extraordinaire
mais il faut se souvenir par exemple
pour françois hollande
la foule était aussi relativement
clairsemé ça traduit plus une attente
qui à mon avis est une atteinte
extrêmement forte
mais les français vont attendre avant de
se mobiliser autour du nouveau président
vont attendre les premières mesures
les premières politiques mises en place
les premières signaux que emmanuel
macron annonce dès son discours
d'investiture et on verra si dans
quelques temps lors de ses premières
sorties véritablement sur le terrain le
peuple est au rendez vous voir en ligne
de mire l'arc de triomphe puisque
emmanuel macron remonte les champs
elysées pour se rendre sous l'arc de
triomphe pour raviver la flamme du
soldat inconnu
les bouillons au fond pour voir
l'événement et vaut mieux être branché
sur lcp et public sénat absolument
et puis faut être courageux pour aller
sous la pluie sous la pluie là où le
risque de contenu des barrières de
sécurité puisque sécurité de ce que la
sécurité impose au spectateur on l'a
bien vu pour les les cérémonies
le précédente et
franchement il faut être courageux 1
vous avez raison la télé sont à mieux il
faut pas oublier que les français
sortent quand même de deux quinquennats
qui les ont profondément déçu que ce
soit sur sur la politique menée comme
sur la forme sur la gouvernance et donc
qui a effectivement cette attente
vis-à-vis des manuels macron mais les
français attendent un peu avant
d'applaudir de français attendent
beaucoup de moi ils ont raison et
d'ailleurs c'est sans doute l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles lui même n'a pas
insisté sur sur son action au niveau
économique puisque c'est vrai que c'est
l'un des inspirateurs de la politique
économique de françois hollande sauf que
françois hollande n'a pas voulu aller
aussi loin qu emmanuel macron lors
évolué alors est ce que c'est à cause de
ça ou pas en tout cas les résultats ont
été jugés décevants et c'est bien pour
ça que françois hollande n'a pas été en
capacité de se représenter
donc emmanuel macron effectivement on ne
veut pas finalement remuer le couteau
dans la plaie et puis le droit
d'inventaire il l'a déjà fait il l'a
fait pendant la campagne elle en
expliquant qu'il voulait tourner la page
avec les vingt dernières années et
précisé t-il même les cinq dernières
années et donc maintenant il va être
dans l'action plutôt que dans dans le
rétroviseur
pascal perrineau sur cette image on a vu
une une cérémonie d'investiture somme
toute assez classique et puis là il y à
ce choix
ce véhicule qui est un véhicule
militaire
emmanuel macron se pose clairement chef
de guerre il sait que il aura du travail
de ce côté là c'est le premier président
élu en situation d'urgence ça n'est pas
rien les français ont ça en tête au
quotidien et les places les attentats ou
l'e tat les anglais tentative d'attentât
nous rappelle au cas où nous le bel
aurions que nous sommes dans une
situation d'urgence donc il ya une
symbolique forte et puis d'autre part
emmanuel macron c'est très bien que là
où le bât peut éventuellement blesser
pour lui c'est une absence de dimension
régalienne donc là il n'hésite pas il
rentre tout de suite dans la fonction et
dans le coeur de la fonction
présidentielle dont le pouvoir régalien
et l'ossature centrale ce sera la
principale tâche la principale mission
d' emmanuel macron cette lutte contre le
terrorisme philippe beaulieu mais il est
très attendu là dessus aussi en faial
effectivement il est attendu sur la
lutte contre le terrorisme et jusqu'à
présent c'est vrai que incarne pas une
ligne extrêmement précises ou affiches
affirmé donc il va devoir très vite
donné des preuves dégage je sais pas
comment on peut dire de sa détermination
à lutter et puis après il ya évidemment
le terrain économique
et puis sur ce choix d'un véhicule
militaire aussi n'oublions pas que il
est haï lilas il est né en 1977 est
comme ça quand il a eu l'âge de faire
son service militaire il y avait plus de
service militaire et il est le premier
président la république dans cette
situation donc il lui fallait très vite
là aussi apporter la preuve que bomba
les questions militaires
il a bien conscience que c'est important
et ludovic faux sur ce terrain là une
des premières décisions ça va être aussi
de maintenir ou non l'état d'urgence un
qui est maintenu un peu après les
élections législatives
will décision hautement symbolique être
maintenue effectivement au moins à court
terme
on verra ce qu'il en est par la suite
mais c'est vrai que genre 15 juillet
mais c'est vrai que dans ces
vraisemblablement il devrait être
ils devraient être maintenues au-delà
c'est ce qu'on a cru comprendre jusque
là il y avait deux vidéos ralliement de
ce qu'on a vu là qu'on était très
important pour emmanuel macron pendant
la campagne c'était celui du ministre de
la défense jean yves le drian évidemment
et puis celui de jean-michel fauvergue
l'ancien patron du raid qui d'ailleurs
candidat aux législatives cours en
marche
en seine et marne c'était vraiment de
ralliement important qui lui ont donné
du poids finalement sur sur ces
questions de terrorisme dont il a dit
que ce serait effectivement l'une de ses
priorités
emmanuel macron qui s'apprête donc à
quitter son véhicule pour remonter à
pied jusqu'à l'arc de triomphe
on parlait de
jean yves le drian l'instant pascal
perrineau est-ce qu'il peut imaginer que
jean yves le drian soit le seul ministre
du gouvernement actuel à rester en place
sous un gouvernement d manueel macro
c'est une hypothèse parce que jean yves
le drian est tout de même dans une
équipe qui fait l'objet d'un assez
profond rejet à tort ou à raison
donc ça nous prononcer là dessus mais
c'est un ministre qui fait l'objet d'un
consensus quand on regarde la structure
de la popularité aujourd'hui de jean
yves le drian et bien c'est une
popularité forte parmi les électeurs de
gauche est forte parmi les électeurs de
droite
et puis sur le bilan civil et de la
politique de défense c'est tout de même
un des ministères dans lequel la
réussite a été la présidente et au 15
août et pourra assurer tout de suite sur
les champs-elysées notre envoyé spécial
valérie brochard qui suit donc cette
remontée des champs elysées à présent à
pied par le chef de l'état oui
absolument je suis avec marie thé qui
est venu de bretagne vous venez de voir
passer le président qu'est ce que c'est
qu'est ce que ça vous a fait et ça nous
a fait beaucoup de bonheur on est super
contentes d'être là aujourd'hui ce
n'était pas prévu mais voilà on est
venus pour passer le week-end et donc on
a profité de venir voir le défilé de
l'émotion un petit peu oui sûrement
beaucoup de alors on attend beaucoup du
président forcément un et mais on est
très contentes d'avoir
petit oubli et puis qui souhaite que ce
soit lui merci beaucoup merci infiniment
merci beaucoup valérie bouchard cette
réaction
oui on comprend mieux après concours où
les spectateurs marseillaise
[Musique]
oui
et
m
voilà c'est la deuxième fois que
retentit la marseillaise jean michel
djian de la matinée détermination de les
mesneux macron de s'attacher les
compétences laura l'autorité de jean
yves le drian
mais pas seulement parce qu'il est
ministre de la défense
les ministres l'enfance incontesté on
n'a pas eu ça depuis pierre messmer
c'était sous de gaulle et pompidou mais
au delà et en plus il se trouve que jean
yves le drian
n'oublions pas et le seul willis qui a
conservé la présidence de la région de
dunes des régions la bretagne la
bretagne qui se trouve être le terrain
exemplaire de ce qu'est le maquereau
nisme l'attend c'est à dire du dialogue
permanent entre les oppositions un
travail de terrain autour de l'intérêt
général dont il ya quelque chose là
aussi de symbolique alors qu'on voit un
emmanuel macron déposer une gerbe sur la
tombe du soldat inconnu c'est donc le
début de cette deuxième cérémonie cette
cérémonie d'hommage au soldat inconnu
emmanuel macron ludovic 1 qui avait déjà
déposé une gerbe sur la tombe du soldat
inconnu avec françois hollande je vis
mes derniers oui avec françois hollande
effectivement comme françois hollande
d'ailleurs avaient accompagné un nicolas
sarkozy en 2000 en 2012
donc effectivement il se finit avec
plusieurs cérémonies en fait la
passation de pouvoir a eu lieu
aujourd'hui mais le passage de relais
finalement dure depuis le début de la
semaine dernière puisque dès lundi
dernier il ya eu la cérémonie du 8 mai
on a revu françois hollande emmanuel
macron ensemble deux jours plus tard le
10 mai dans l'est dans les jardins du
luxembourg pour commémorer l'abolition
de l'esclavagé et ont donc voit donc
aujourd'hui que c'est l'aboutissement
d'un processus de plusieurs jours qui
qui aboutissent finalement au fait qu
emmanuel macron est désormais pleinement
président de la république